[موسيقى] أجنبية
أننا أه نبتكر طريقة
الترفيه قبل أن يكون الترفيه في أغلب الأحيان
قائمًا على أساس مادي ، يجب أن تكون هناك
شخصيًا لتتمكن من الاستمتاع بهذا النوع
من الترفيه ، لذا فإن الرؤية آه هي
شيء نبتكره ولا
حدود له  إلى الفضاء ،
تخيل أنك
لنفترض أنك إذا كنت في البرازيل ،
وتريد أن تحضر أه الحفلة الموسيقية لموسيقى
الدي جي المفضلة لديك أو المشاهير المفضلين لديك ،
ولكن بعد ذلك ستحتاج إلى قضاء
وقتك في السفر بالطائرة إلى
مكان ما  بحاجة إلى
إنفاق أموالك على السفر فقط من
أجل الانتقال من مكان "أ" إلى "مكان" ب "
في المستقبل ، نعتقد أنه بدلاً
من الاضطرار إلى الانتقال من النقطة" أ "إلى النقطة"
ب "، يمكنك فقط وضع نظاراتك الواقية
وبنقرة واحدة يمكنك ذلك  في أي مكان
تريد أن تكون فيه ،
نحن متحمسون جدًا للإعلان عن
أننا سنكون أول نادي
ميتافيرس في العالم أه سنحظى برؤية
النادي المادي
والنادي metaverse
الذي سنقوم به أيضًا  لدينا ساعات Jacob and Co Vision الخاصة بنا ،
لذلك
لن يتمكن الأشخاص من شراء
هذه الساعات أو من المحتمل أن يكونوا قادرين على
الحصول على هذه الساعات الرائعة جدًا التي
يصممها Jacob Eco uh لنا وسيحتاجون إلى شراء nfts ليكونوا  قادرًا على
لعب إحدى مسابقاتنا
التي سنفعلها كل شهر ، وبناءً على
هذه المسابقات ، يتمكن هؤلاء الأشخاص
من الحصول على هذه الساعات
، أعتقد أن المعادلة ستستغرق
جزءًا كبيرًا من صناعة الترفيه
وأنا أؤمن بذلك
المستقبل ليس جيلنا ولكن
جيلنا القادم سيعيشون في
واقع مختلف كثيرًا نعيشه بشكل
صحيح لذلك أعتقد أن
الترفيه سوف يعتمد في الغالب على
metaverse